[Applause]
what's up guys we are found in Italy so
a few weeks ago we asked for your
challenge ideas on Instagram and today
we'll be trying them out let's see what
you came up with this episode is
sponsored by north VPN tarik right VPN
offer for you which we'll talk more
about later on and now to the challenges
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
you won't even try to get that and say
what this makes no sense there's a
reason why there's a net in table tennis
this is actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with a bit out of hand maybe I think
it's time to get the next challenge it's
time to set the table upside down
[Music]
there we go this is gonna be so
difficult
it doesn't really bounce
doesn't this is not the easiest
challenge
[Music]
Oh Chris point was that yes
[Music]
ya know
in the world's fastest upside-down table
sir
left her right hand between the legs a
tense
liftoff
[Music]
[Applause]
okay first let's use this as a racket
[Music]
oh this is good exercise that's why it's
called exercise boy sure this is
actually the original purpose of an
exercise ball this is what they don't
tell you in the manual but this is how
you actually should use it
[Music]
I can't believe that actually worked
[Music]
what are you doing I don't know I've got
a new approach for this one
[Music]
over how did I get it over I did a jack
valenti myself the knee I did the fruit
for 40 plus plus plus plus
[Applause]
[Music]
lucky for him
come on so guys y'all wanting us to play
with the bottom part of the racket so
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
roller okay now more about Nord VPN who
is sponsoring this episode
Nord VPN is offering a 70 percent
discount on a three year plan so go to
nod VPN comm slash Punk finiti and if
you use the promotion code pond Finity
you'll get an additional one month for
free okay so for those who don't know
what a VPN is it stands for virtual
private network and essentially that
means it allows you to access websites
and online services privately and
securely
so basically when you're browsing online
your information is jumping around the
internet just like this ball and someone
can jump in to intercept it but if
you're using Nord VPN your information
is encrypted so it travels through a VPN
server to whichever website you're
connecting to which basically makes it a
lot more difficult for anybody to Incept
your information Nord VPN has thousands
of servers all around the world
which helps keep servers really fast
wherever you are if you travel a lot and
use a lot of public Wi-Fi for example
hotel Wi-Fi is Airport Wi-Fi it's really
useful to have a VPN and since some
videos aren't available in all countries
with north VPN you can watch pumping
into videos all over the world so go
check out the offer on Nod VPN comm
/font finis e and big Faxon or via pian
for sponsoring this video until next
time
[Music]